hello and welcome to this blitz video
yeah I'm ready to do a man to make
produce some new videos my voice is back
and yeah it's still a little bit a
little bit off but I'm think I'm able to
make some videos so let's get going I
also will I also will produce a new part
of the opening here named on the weekend
so look forward to that
probably on Saturday or Sunday I'm not
sure maybe also tomorrow Friday 29th I
need to need to see what my schedule is
like I'm mostly writing my new project
the keep it simple deform and
[Music]
the opening videos they always take a
bit of a bit of time you need to go
through the questions and I mean some
things I can answer quite quickly but
some are just too sophisticated to just
do on the fly okay here we have a an
Evans gambit and the way white played it
I think I'm more or less porn up for no
compensation it looks all very that
looks very slow what do I did and yeah I
have the b-pawn
which is indeed somewhat important here
you could think that the b-pawn is not
the most important part but it has some
relevance one thing in particular stands
out here is that white playing d5 is
basically never an option because then
the Queen's side will be completely
frozen and that it's not what white
wants I get to see five square
after you place d5 there this yeah this
is something that is strategically very
desirable for me now the Queen side is
completely closed and I can play on the
King side in fact without worrying at
all about the other side of the board
so how am I going to play this there are
a couple of options I'm going to play h5
using the fact that I have not castled
you have b6p it's not a move that I love
to play
but Ruby Aegis is difficult to do he's
got Bishop a4 I just recognize that ever
play b6
mm that is not ideal okay so let's pray
wait I don't want to give him access to
c6
does it look right
my idea of h5 was to maybe even play h4
secure the g5 square and then that is
funny because that was my next move
anyway yeah still sometimes not on 100%
Yahoo with my with so here I had the
Queen is attacking the bond think I
could waste six
come on a six he can go Quinta a seven
but after Knight b6 that has no square
now one of the idea was night 2h7 at
Bishop g5 and now is giving me the e5
square as well that is something that I
don't mind at all so 95 get the square
on e5 attack the bishop and I think it
is really hanging green takes f7 is not
an issue
now Bishop g5 I guess so it let's like
activate this piece
you
no young Knights e4 doesn't quite work
there is some the check check on deform
you know the easiest smooth green is
this one easiest I mean the most obvious
move is this one now I can at least play
Knight c4 I think I'm going to do that
he has to play Bishop c1 and then I can
just trade which I'm happy with
Tempe with happy about I don't know I'm
still just upon up for nothing
yeah but how to win this is often
different manner and you know that
everything is fine but you still have to
of course put him away I'm trying to
play Queen g5 as an idea
activate the Queen that night might also
go to c5
the main claim for an advantage besides
upon years that I have a night and he's
got that really rotten Bishop 1 C 2 that
is not going to be activated anytime
soon
I have fancy moves like rock edge five I
don't think it's bad
let's go for it prepare Queen g5 or even
rook g5 it's a way to activate this
piece yeah here I was thinking rook g5
I can even go to g3 maybe one yeah let's
put this here
25
I can't go to
go to 83
I don't have anything better
what is g5g five Queen f5 huh
okay well Brooke d3 he might play Bishop
c2
it isn't all that great actually him
interesting I did not really a spot that
my rook was so short of squares
Queen f6 maybe I need to play quicker
96 that have move nothing
I can I go here
before I could have taken already
I want to play somewhat quickly so
that I'm not running into any anytime
issues
just playing good moves quickly as
enough him
yeah let's go here the Aparna is another
additional weakness
you
yeah yeah I think it was a very
comfortable position out of the opening
it's here this is rather rather
important Bishop d3 is a good move that
is not bad at all
I went t six returning the pond it here
white should simply take the pond there
was just no reason to not do that get
the pawn back I think the position here
is maybe about equal you have equal
material now White's pawn structure is
slightly compromised him but yes captain
additional pawn in the center that
controls the porn squares you see the
engineer gives white a small advantage
now it goes to zero and then usual
theoretical verdict is that it is
roughly equal so that is what white
should do the problem with not taking is
he went castles said that now just
returned and basically claim this is a
completely normal looking position
besides the fact that this pawn is just
missing yeah I mean white has gotten
maybe one tempo one or two maybe but
it's a closed position and that's the
thing
why does not really getting any pressure
going against e5 and I can catch up with
my development and the way it went
I'm just a pawn up for not much we
should perform yeah now I'm pressurizing
the d4 pawn already so it's a bit
difficult now d5 is not a move that
white loves to play it is not much else
I went back and here I'm just born up
for basically nothing you can argue
about the best play from here that is
definitely a k7 age 5 rupee one rupee
eight all this should be fine Queen e5
was funny because g6 was my next move
anyway
the engine we have kind of approves can
you have eight just doing all the
improvements that you need and I think
like here this is some yeah just pawn
basically but but has some activity that
I cannot so easily get into some sort of
conversion phase however night b3 is
kind of weird but okay now after f4 I
think the advantage grows to almost
decisive proportions of you check here
I've got all the active pieces and
probably I didn't play it in the best
possible way I'm with hindsight I'm not
sure that the trade was all that helpful
but you can do it it's not a big problem
at all he can check here but I can just
go back and then there are two hanging
pieces yeah woo cage five intending to
place a piece on a g5 which now happened
and now I went to g3 which is probably
not helping and just have to go back but
you see that the computer eval doesn't
change and here should probably keep the
Queen's on to have some more swindle
insurances here just winning her think
we have the pawn and I had 93 okay I was
just like take the second pawn and with
a completely
yes simple to play position okay guys
thanks for watching